t
pour lui, pour rendre hommage à
la sommité du jazz de Montréal.
- Oscar Peterson avait donné
le nom d'une place à un
de ses plus grands succès.
- La place Saint-Henri se situe
dans le quartier de Montréal
où je suis né.
- C'est maintenant l'inverse
qui se produit. Le Maharaja
du piano, comme le surnommait
Duke Ellington, aura une place
en son honneur.
L'un des plus grands
ambassadeurs culturels
de notre ville.
Cet espace sera niché
dans le réaménagement prévu
de l'avenue McGill College
en 2023. Et là, entre Sainte-
Catherine et Maisonneuve,
une fontaine, de la verdure,
une place entièrement piétonne.
Ce lieu a été préféré
à la Place des Festivals.
- C'est au coeur de la cité,
c'est pas seulement un endroit
dédié à la culture, c'est un
endroit dédié à toute la vie,
de l'urbanité de Montréal.
- Et pour la veuve d'Oscar
Peterson, c'est l'endroit
parfait.
- Oscar Peterson était le mentor
du pianiste Oliver Jones. On les
voyait faire Montréal en 2004
interprétant "Just Freinds".
Lui aussi a fait le déplacement
pour l'annonce.
- Et pour la ville, cet hommage
dépasse le seul musicien.
- Il faut pas oublier non plus
que M. Peterson, de par
la couleur de sa peau, a vécu
beaucoup de discrimination
et de racisme.
- Mais cette future place
d'environ 500 mètres carrés
manque un peu d'envergure,
selon la Ligue des Noirs.
- C'est loin d'être suffisant
compte tenu de l'importance,
de la grandeur de Oscar Peterson
dans l'univers musical du jazz.
- C'est en tout cas davantage
que le petit parc qui porte
actuellement son nom
dans la Petite-Bourgogne.
- Je veux vous remercier
pour cet honneur.
- Oscar Peterson est mort
il y a déjà 14 ans.
Mais il continue de donner
la chair de poule.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, M